cuando estamos haciendo mecanismos de
reacción y dos para ciclohexano
sustituidos la clave la pista más
importante es utilizar las
conformaciones de silla porque por
ejemplo vamos a intentar hacer el
mecanismo 2 con este ciclo hexano sin
utilizar las conformaciones de silla y
vamos a ver qué pasa pues empezamos por
aquí el cloro está enlazado con el
carbono al que le llamamos el carbono
alfa y luego los carbonos directamente
enlazados con el carbono alza son los
carbonos beta a éste le vamos a llamar
beta 1 y ya este le vamos a llamar beta
2 por acá además nos dicen que el óxido
de sodio es nuestra base y es una base
fuerte entonces llega el anillo net
óxido y se lleva un protón de algunos de
los carbonos beta y entonces se va a
formar un doble enlace entre alguno de
estos carbonos beta y el carbono alfa y
al mismo tiempo el cloro se va
si es que es el tóxico de sodio toma un
protón del carbono beta uno se forma un
doble enlace entre el carbono alfa y el
carbono beta 1 el átomo de cloro ya se
fue pero seguimos teniendo este grupo
metilo es un grupo metilo que dibujamos
con una línea punteada por lo que se
está alejando de nosotros y listo este
es uno de los posibles productos de esta
reacción pero podemos tener otro pues
aquí podemos pensar en que se puede
formar un doble enlace entre el carbono
beta 2 y el carbono alfa pero entonces
el grupo metilo lo tendríamos aquí con
una línea recta ya no se está alejando
de nosotros y bueno si podríamos pensar
que este puede ser otro de nuestros
productos pero si nos fijamos en nuestra
conformación de silla nos vamos a dar
cuenta de que este producto no se puede
formar cuando realicemos esta reacción
solo vamos a observar este producto y
por supuesto ahora vamos a ver por qué
sucede esto ahora para hacer eso primero
tenemos que enumerar los carbonos de
ésta
formación de silla y recuerda cuando
estamos numerando a un ciclohexano para
su conformación de silla no
necesariamente estamos utilizando la
nomenclatura iupac solo estamos
utilizando los números para poder
dibujar de forma adecuada la
conformación de silla vamos a empezar
por el carbono que tiene el cloro ese va
a ser el carbono 1 y luego nos vamos a
ir hacia el carbono beta 1 entonces este
es el carbono 2 3 4 5 y 6
entonces aquí no estamos nombrando a los
carbonos simplemente usamos estos
números para encontrar la conformación
de silla por acá en esta conformación de
silla yo siempre digo que este es el
carbono 1 y bueno el cloro se encuentra
en el carbono 1 y se encuentra por acá
viendo hacia nosotros así es que en esta
conformación de silla se tiene que ver
axial hacia arriba entonces por aquí
está él
y luego si queremos ir al carbono 6
bueno pues este es el carbono 2 3 4 5 y
6 y en el carbono 6 tenemos un grupo
metilo que se está alejando de nosotros
entonces en la conformación de silla
tiene que estar hacia abajo porque por
aquí tiene que estar
este grupo metilo pero simplemente le
vamos a poner una m
que represente al grupo metilo y está en
posición axial abajo pero bueno ahora
vamos a dibujar los protones de los
carbonos beta estos dos son los carbonos
beta este es beta 1 este es beta 2 y
aquí vete a uno tiene dos hidrógenos
este hidrógeno y este otro hidrógeno
mientras que beta 2 tiene el grupo
metilo y únicamente otro hidrógeno y es
un hidrógeno que se encuentra en
posición ecuatorial y ahora pasaremos a
un vídeo en el que podemos ver cuál de
estos protones puede participar en un
mecanismo de reacción 2 tenemos aquí la
conforman
y podemos ver aquí en el carbono alfa en
una posición arriba axial al átomo de
cloro de amarillo si nos vamos ahora al
carbono beta aún no podemos ver que sólo
el hidrógeno verde se encuentra en
posición anti peri planear con el cloro
si rotamos un poquito la molécula así es
más fácil ver que los cuatro átomos se
encuentran en un mismo plano entonces
aquí el protón verde se encuentra en una
posición anti peri planar con el cloro
el otro hidrógeno el hidrógeno de blanco
no se encuentra en una posición anti
peri planar con el cloro entonces no
puede participar en nuestro mecanismo 2
pero ahora pasemos al carbono beta 2
este hidrógeno de blanco no es anti peri
planar y si nos fijamos en la posición
abajo axial está ocupada por este grupo
metilo y aquí es donde necesitaría estar
el átomo de hidrógeno para poder
participar en el mecanismo de reacción
de 2
que un ciclo extraño sustituido pueda
participar en un mecanismo de reacción
2el a lo que no se tiene que encontrar
en una posición axial aquí si tenemos a
nuestro halógeno en una posición axial
pero ahora en esta conformación de silla
el único hidrógeno que se encuentra en
una posición anti peri planar es este
hidrógeno que en el vídeo estaba de
color verde así es que el mecanismo
sucede así llega a una base fuerte se
lleva a este protón los electrones de
este enlace se pasan para acá para
formar un doble enlace y al mismo tiempo
el cloro se va llevándose a los
electrones de su enlace
entonces se forma un enlace entre el
carbono alfa y el carbono beta uno
dándonos este producto no se puede
formar un doble enlace entre el carbono
alfa y el carbono beta 2 porque el
carbono beta 2 tiene un grupo metilo
donde necesitaríamos que tuviera un
hidrógeno
en lugar de este grupo metilo tuviéramos
un hidrógeno entonces ese hidrógeno si
estaría en posición anti peri planar con
el halógeno y obtendríamos un doble
enlace aquí pero como no es así
obtenemos únicamente este producto y
logramos observar esto porque dibujamos
nuestra conformación de silla ahora
vamos a hacer otro mecanismo de reacción
de dos con otro ciclohexano sustituido
pero esta vez vamos a empezar numerando
nuestro ciclohexano este es el carbono 1
este es el 2 el 3 y el 4 esta numeración
no es para la nomenclatura es
simplemente para ayudarnos a dibujar
nuestra conformación de silla entonces
si a éste le llamó el carbono 1 tenemos
un grupo metilo en posición arriba axial
y luego en el carbono 3 tenemos un cloro
hacia abajo así es que si este es el
carbono 1
este es el carbono 2
este el carbono 3 por lo que tenemos un
cloro hacia abajo ecuatorial en el
carbono 4 tenemos un grupo isopropílico
entonces nos vamos para que el carbono 4
y esto lo que nos dice es que tenemos un
grupo y sobró pilot en posición abajo
axial este es nuestro grupo isopropílico
para que suceda un mecanismo de reacción
de 2 en un ciclo hexano sustituido el
halo que no tiene que estar en una
posición axial pero en esta conformación
de silla el halo que no se encuentra en
una posición ecuatorial entonces aquí
primero tenemos que pensar en una
rotación del anillo por acá tenemos la
otra conformación de este anillo solo
que ahora este es el carbono 1 y ahora
el grupo metilo que estaba en una
posición arriba axial ahora está en una
posición arriba ecuatorial
este es el carbono 2 el carbono 3 y en
el carbono 3 teníamos un cloro en
posición abajo ecuatorial pero ahora en
esta otra conformación de silla el cloro
está en una posición abajo axial y luego
en el carbono 4 tengo un grupo
isopropílico hacia abajo en la
conformación de silla de la izquierda el
grupo hizo pro pilot estaba en una
posición hacia abajo axial pero en esta
ahora está en una posición hacia abajo
ecuatorial y listo ahora tenemos al
cloro en una posición axial este es
nuestro carbono alfa y veamos qué pasa
con los carbonos beta por aquí está un
carbono beta al que le vamos a llamar
beta 1 y acá tenemos otro carbono beta
al que le vamos a llamar beta 2 y ahora
lo que vamos a hacer es buscar
hidrógenos en estos dos carbonos beta
que se encuentran en una posición anti
peri plan ar con el halógeno en el
carbono beta aún no tenemos este
hidrógeno que es anti peri plan ar
y en el carbono beta 2 también tenemos
este hidrógeno que es anti peri planar
estos son los dos protones que podemos
perder en el mecanismo 2
pero bueno antes de ponernos a dibujar
los productos antes vamos a ver qué tan
estable es esta conformación de silla en
comparación con esta otra conformación
de silla en vídeos anteriores hemos
visto que para que una conformación sea
más estable queremos colocar a los
grupos estorbosos en una posición
ecuatorial o sea en una posición hacia
los lados por aquí tenemos este grupo
isopropílico muy estorboso y en esta
conformación lo tenemos en una posición
ecuatorial mientras que en esta otra
conformación este grupo hizo pro pilot
muy estorbos o se encuentra en una
posición axial en la que tiene mucha más
interacción con el resto de la molécula
entonces la conformación de silla de la
derecha es
más estable y vamos a ver un vídeo donde
explicamos esto de una forma más visual
en el carbono 1 tenemos un grupo metilo
que está arriba axial este es el carbono
2 y este es el carbono 3 con el átomo de
cloro en posición ecuatorial y en el
carbono 4 tenemos nuestro grupo
isopropílico que está en posición abajo
axial y podemos ver todo este
impedimento estético que desestabiliza a
esta molécula lo que ya está es la
conformación menos estable por lo que
vamos a ver la rotación de este anillo
es un poco difícil hacerlo con este
modelo pero aquí tenemos aproximadamente
la otra conformación de silla ahora en
el carbono 1 el grupo metilo se
encuentra hacia arriba ecuatorial y en
el carbono 3 ahora tenemos al cloro en
una posición abajo axial y en el carbono
4 el grupo isopropílico ahora está en
una posición abajo ecuatorial o sea que
está hacia afuera por aquí este carbono
en la
con el átomo de cloro es el carbono alfa
y el carbón o directamente enlazado con
él es el carbono beta y uno de sus
hidrógenos está en posición anti peri
planar con él a lo que no fuera que
tenemos otro carbono beta con otro
hidrógeno que también se encuentra en
posición anti peri planar con el
halógeno bueno ahora sí vamos a dibujar
los productos de esta reacción primero
vamos a quitarle un hidrógeno al carbono
beta 1 entonces por aquí tenemos una
base fuerte que llega y se lleva este
protón los electrones de este enlace se
pasan para acá para formar un doble
enlace y al mismo tiempo los electrones
de este enlace se dan con el átomo de
cloro fernando una unión cloruro como
nuestro grupo saliente por lo que aquí
se forma un enlace doble entre el
carbono 2 y el carbono 3
ok porque aquí dijimos que este el
carbono 1 entonces este es el carbono 2
y 4 también tenemos un grupo metilo en
el carbono 1 dibujamos el grupo metilo
por acá con una cuña porque está hacia
arriba viendo hacia nosotros así es que
si este es el carbono 1
este es el carbono 2 y este es el
carbono 3 y aquí es donde se forma el
doble enlace entre el carbono 2 y el
carbono 3 y luego en el carbono 4
tenemos un grupo iso pro pilot hacia
abajo entonces lo dibujamos con una
línea punteada y listo este es uno de
los productos que obtenemos ahora si la
base fuerte en lugar de llevarse este
protón se lleva este otro protón
entonces los electrones de este enlace
se pasan para acá para formar un doble
enlace y los electrones de acá se van
con el cloro para formar una unión
cloruro así es que si le quitamos un
protón al carbono beta 2 se forma un
doble enlace entre el carbono 3 y el
carbono 4 aquí está el enlace doble
entre los carbonos 3 y 4
también tenemos un grupo metilo en el
carbono al que yo le llamo carbono 1 y
también tenemos un grupo hizo pro pilot
en el carbono 4 pero ahora este carbono
tiene hibridación esp 4 entonces tenemos
que dibujarlo con una línea recta en
lugar de una línea punteada algunos
alumnos a veces ponen este grupo y sobró
pilot con una cuña o con una línea
punteada pero tenemos que ponerlo con
una línea recta para denotar la
geometría plana de este carbono así es
que necesitamos aquí una línea recta y
listo
estos son los dos posibles productos de
esta reacción bueno vamos con otro
ejemplo de estos como podemos ver este
sustrato es muy parecido al que acabamos
de ver pero la diferencia entre el
ejemplo anterior y éste es que ahora el
cloro está en una cuña en lugar de una
línea punteada podemos numerar este
ciclo hexano de esta forma
para ahorrar tiempo ya puse aquí las dos
con formaciones de silla y entonces este
es el carbono 1 este es el 2 el 3 y el 4
en la otra conformación de silla
este es el carbono uno el dos el tres y
el cuatro y observa en la conformación
de silla de la izquierda tenemos el
átomo de cloro en una posición arriba
axial entonces este es el carbono alfa y
aquí tenemos estos dos carbonos beta y
ahora necesitamos un protón que se
encuentra en posición anti peri planar
pero en esta conformación el único es
este de acá entonces llega a una base
fuerte y se lleva este protón los
electrones de este enlace se pasan para
acá para formar un doble enlace y los
electrones de este enlace se van con el
cloro y el producto que nos queda es
éste por lo que primero ponemos nuestro
ciclohexano en el carbono 1 tenemos un
grupo metilo hacia arriba por lo que lo
vamos a poner con una cuña
y carbono 1 carbono 2 carbono 3 el doble
enlace se formó entre el carbono 2 y el
carbono 3 por lo que el doble enlace se
formó aquí y luego tenemos el grupo
isopropílico hacia abajo en el carbono 4
este es el carbono 4 y como está hacia
abajo lo ponemos con una línea punteada
y listo
terminamos este es el único producto que
puede tener esta reacción porque tenemos
un solo protón en posición anti peri
planar con el cloro ahora de todas
formas tenemos que pensar en estas dos
con formaciones de silla en esta
conformación de silla en la que sucede
el mecanismo de reacción tenemos todos
nuestros grupos estorbosos en una
posición axial mientras que en la
conformación de silla de la derecha
todos los grupos estorbosos se
encuentran en una posición ecuatorial
así es que esta conformación de silla de
la derecha es mucho más estable esta es
más estable porque todos los grupos
estorbosos
hacia afuera de la molécula lo cual
significa que esta reacción es
relativamente lenta es una reacción
lenta porque el equilibrio favorece la
conformación en la que los grupos
estorbosos están hacia afuera en una
posición ecuatorial pero esa no es la
conformación en la que puede suceder el
mecanismo de reacción de dos la
conformación que sí tiene las
condiciones necesarias para que suceda
la reacción es la menos estable aunque
hay por aquí tenemos el hidrógeno en
posición anti peri planar con el cloro
pero esta es la conformación menos
estable entonces esta reacción es mucho
más lenta que la que vimos antes aquí
tenemos la reacción anterior por aquí
también el equilibrio favorece la
conformación en la que los grupos
estorbosos se encuentran en posición
ecuatorial el equilibrio favorece esta
conformación de silla
y es en esta conformación de silla en la
que puede suceder la reacción en esta
conformación tenemos a los hidrógenos en
posición anti peri planar con el
halógeno entonces esta reacción es mucho
más rápida